BUT FIRST, AND NANCY'S MAGNET,
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
>> OVER THE WEEKEND NANCY PELOSI
CONVINCED THE PRESIDENT TO CALL
OFF ITS PROMISED REMOVAL OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO REFUSED
TO APPEAR FOR DEPORTATION.
DESPITE OUTSTANDING COURT
ORDERS.
NOW, THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE
AWAITING EMIGRATION OR ASYLUM
HEARINGS CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU
THINK SPEAK NO TRUTH PELOSI.
>> SO I SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT
AND I SAID LOOK, I AM A MOM AND
I HAVE KIDS.
I HAVE NINE GRANDCHILDREN.
AND YOUR CHILDREN ARE SCARED.
AND I DO THINK THAT SOMEONE
THINKS THESE GROUPS WEIGHED IN
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
I HOPE SO.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO KEEP THAT
PRESSURE ON.
>> Sean:
>> Lean:
>> Laun:
>> Laura: NOTICE HER TYPICAL
PLOY, HER CHILDREN, TO GET HER
WAY.
EXCEPT WHEN SHE WANTS THEIR
LIVES ENDED.
NO ONE WANTS ANY CHILD EVER TO
BE AFRAID, EVER.
IT IS TRAGIC, AND IT REALLY
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN.
AND KIDS OF AMERICAN CRIMINALS,
THEY SUFFER HERE TOO BECAUSE OF
THE MISTAKES OF THEIR PARENTS.
AND PARENTS COMING ILLEGALLY,
AGAIN TRAGIC BUT NOW COMES THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE WHOLE
FAMILY SOMETIMES.
OR AT LEAST THERE SHOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES IF THE RULE OF LAW
MEANS ANYTHING.
BY THE WAY, IF WE CARED ABOUT
KIDS, WHAT ABOUT SOME OF THE
STUFF THAT IS HAPPENING TO
AMERICAN KITTIES -- KIDS, THOSE
ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS OR KIDS THES
ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS OR KIDS THEL
ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS OR KIDS THEE
ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS OR KIDS THES
WHO ARE ADDICTS?
NANCY DOESN'T NEED TO GO FAR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO SEE
SUFFERING AND DESPERATION.
WE HAVE SEEN ALL THOSE STORIES.
MAYBE SHE SHOULD FOCUS ON FIXING
THAT BEFORE THROWING ROCKS.
MEANWHILE, HER PARTY RATHER THAN
WORKING WITH THE PRESIDENT TO
SOLVE THE BORDER CRISIS,
INSTEAD, SPENT ITS TIME SUCKING
UP TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
>> WE NEED TO PASS A FEDERAL LAW
TO MAKE ROE VS. WADE RULE OF THE
LAW [APPLAUSE]
>> WOMEN INCARCERATED FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS, THEY
DESERVE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE BECAUSE HEALTH CARE
IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
>> Laura: LET'S GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
THEY CARE SO MUCH ABOUT THE
CHILDREN THAT THEY ARE TAKING
ORDERS FROM THE ORGANIZATION
THAT EXIST TO DESTROY THE
CHILDREN.
OKAY.
NOW, THAT RESISTANCE MADE IT
DENIED A CRISIS ALL, JUST
REMEMBER THAT THEY SUPPOSEDLY
CARE ABOUT CHILDREN AND
EVERYBODY ELSE MORE THAN YOU DO.
>> MIKE PENCE IS LYING ABOUT
CHILDREN LIVING IN TORTUROUS
PHYSICIANS ALLOWING CHILDREN TO
WALK AROUND LIES AND WALK AROUND
WITHOUT DIAPERS.
>> WE HAVE MONEY TO GIVE TO
BLANKS -- BLANKETS TO THESE
KIDS.
>> Laura: GIVEN THE SHEER
VOLUME OF FAMILIES WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT, HUNDREDS CROSSING
AT ONE TIME AND TENS OF
THOUSANDS COMING ACROSS IN ONE
MONTH, JUST FAMILY UNITS, OF
COURSE, A BORDER PATROL
PROCESSING CENTER WILL BE
SCRAMBLING TO KEEP UP.
WE SAW IT WITH OUR OWN EYES AND
THEY ARE DOING UNBELIEVABLE
WORK.
BUT AWFUL SITUATIONS WILL
ARRIVE.
BUT WHERE WERE THE DEMOCRATS?
WHERE WERE THEIR OUTRAGE BEFORE
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME INTO
OFFICE?
REMEMBER THE MOST COMPASSIONATE,
COOLEST PRESIDENT EVER SAID
THIS...
DO NOT SEND YOUR CHILDREN TO THE
BORDERS.
IF THEY DO MAKE IT, THEY WILL
GET SENT BACK BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THEY MAY NOT MAKE
IT.
>> Laura: TO DEMONSTRATE HOW
WOEFULLY DISHONEST AND PURPOSELY
MISLEADING THE MEDIA HAS BEEN ON
THE CHILD'S ATTENTION, CONSIDER
THE FINDINGS MADE BY U.S.
DISTRICT COURT JUDGE DOLLY G AND
OBAMA APPOINTEE FROM THE CENTRAL
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA.
SHE FOUND THAT MIGRANT CHILDREN
HAD BEEN HELD WIDESPREAD
DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS BUT
FURTHER THE FEDERAL AUTHORITIES
HAD WHOLLY FAILED TO PROVIDE
SAFE AND SANITARY CONDITIONS
REQUIRED FOR CHILDREN EVEN
TEMPORARY CELLS.
DO YOU KNOW WHOM SHE WAS
CASCADING THEY ARE?
THE ADMINISTRATION.
YES, IT WAS OBAMA'S DHS
SUPPOSEDLY RUNNING THE FLEMISH
RADICALS ARE CALLING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
>> IT'S BEEN THAT WAY FOR A LONG
TIME.
AN OBAMA, PRESIDENT OBAMA BUILT
JAIL CELLS.
THEY WERE BILLED.
>> Laura: NOW, DO ANY OF YOU
REMEMBER NANCY PELOSI FIRING OFF
ANGRY TWEETS IN DEMANDING A
CHANGE IN OBAMA POLICY OR
CRITICIZING THESE ALLEGEDLY
INHUMANE CONDITIONS?
JEH JOHNSON WAS TRYING TO APPEAL
THAT RULING REMEMBER.
AND HOLLYWOOD STARLETS SPEAKING
OUT?
NO AND NO.
TRUMP HAS BEEN TRYING TO MANAGE
THIS IMMIGRATION DISASTER.
HE INHERITED AS A PRESIDENT BUT
GIVEN THE ARBITRARY RULES LAID
DOWN BY JUDGES, AT THE
ADMINISTRATION REPEATEDLY ASKED
CONGRESS TO FIND MORE BEDS FOR
DETENTION FACILITIES AND THEY
NEED MORE MONEY.
GUESS WHAT, CONGRESS REFUSED AND
NOW THEY BLAME HIM FOR THE
PROBLEM?
HAS HE TOLD CHUCK TODD.
>> I'M DOING A FANTASTIC JOB
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT APPROVING
GIVING THIS MONEY.
WHERE'S THE MONEY?
YOU KNOW WHAT, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
HOLDING UP HUMANITARIAN AID.
>> Laura: AND HOW THE
PRESIDENT DELAYED DEPORTATION
PLANS THIS WEEK AND HOPING
CONGRESS WILL WORK TOGETHER IN
HIS WORDS TO WORK OUT A SOLUTION
FOR THE ASYLUM LOOPHOLE PROBLEM.
IT IS NOW INCREASINGLY CLEAR
THIS IS NOT IN THE CARDS.
PELOSI AND A STATEMENT ONLY
AGREES TO SPEND YOUR TAX DOLLARS
ON THE CARE AND TRANSPORTATION
OF ILLEGALS AND OF COURSE DON'T
FORGET THE MONEY TO HIRE LAWYERS
FOR THEM TO FIGHT THEIR
DEPORTATION.
>> WHERE IS THE ASYLUM?
WHERE IS THE FIX?
THESE ARE QUICK MEASURES THAT
THE CONGRESS CAN DEAL WITH
LEGISLATIVE NEEDS AND THE
PRESIDENT IS ASKING FOR THEM TO
DO THAT.
>> Laura: BUT IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE PELOSI IS INTERESTED IN
DOING ANY OF THAT, ESPECIALLY
SINCE CONGRESS IS ONLY IN
SESSION UNTIL THIS FRIDAY.
A MESSAGE FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
AND A BIT BUT DON'T BE DECEIVED
BY THE MEDIA COVERAGE WHERE THE
MOTIVE IMAGES YOU ARE SEEING
BECAUSE IT HAPPENED YEARS AGO
AND THE DEMOCRATS WERE SILENT.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO ELIMINATE
ALL THIS TENSIONS AND THE
POLITICIANS, CORRUPT LAWYERS,
NGOs WILL CHARACTERIZE ALMOST
ANY HOLDING FACILITY AS A
CONCENTRATION CAMP AND THEN SHUT
THEM DOWN.
SO NO DETENTION, NO DEPORTATION
EVER.
ULTIMATELY THEY HOPE FULL VOTING
RIGHTS TO THOSE WHO CAME
ILLEGAL, END OF STORY.
PELOSI WILL NOT IN THIS CRISIS.